how much energy would be used if you
could do this I suppose to split water
into hydrogen and deuterium I guess the
question could you attach your Fusion
reactor energy source coming out in the
back end and put it into a centrifuge
you know it's just series of centrifuges
what is the potential I mean
desalination of the ocean scrubbing the
atmosphere of carbon dioxide do you
think these will ever come true my big
question is can civilization hold on
long enough until we get to the point
where we can get there and also honestly
I I wonder whether we have a society
that would allow a free energy solution
or whether we kind of always have
commercial barrier of course it's
theoretically the way we humans behave I
think scarcity is built into her bones
and I'm not sure we'd let go of it so
quickly